yoth monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve puisque vous l'avez demandé à
peu près un milliard 600 millions 3
mondial j'espère que ça va vous plaire
quand tellement bon visionnage et
jambières toi fils de chien ok ok mais
quand elles sont les milieux découvre
ses marais le jeu des chaises musicales
on y va
et pour l'arrêter chez toi et bouge pas
mis à l'eau de meetic hâtez-vous spa
médias se bouge
ah ouais merde quand vous appuyez sur
rue à chaque fois tevez a mis quatre
heures assez impressionnante à diego
aller ailleurs alors michael pachter
dernière et les cas tu viens retourne
toi dans les dates a semaine par contre
bon mika je vais t'emmener che guérilla
politique sociale
le premier car ils vont le retrouver on
avance oui vous avez bien vu et bien sûr
mais attendez
j'ai rien fait j'ai rien fait l'apport
yabi cac est partie au fait quoi à des
rouges
c'est plus sur le bloc le rouge mc alger
avec un langage rebeu starter en
revanche notre coiffure
ah ouais tu veux trop bon wayne rooney
et heskey à la retraite soit après que
je pense tartas il est lu lan guardian
en revanche et c'est le pod certains
vous êtes juste le cuistot 9 a pris 0
cause et mais québec les maintient pas
moins que chaque roupies qui se bat
beaucoup ils ont continué à l'est
[Rires]
bon admettons mais glisse et ta d'hubert
sur la tête et j'ai les cheveux gras ce
matin allez je vais voir tout le monde
danse et dès que ça s'arrête plus
personnel dans ce dernier qui s'est
arrêté je vais de mal cech sur les murs
de la charlerie tchèque a personne qui
vous attend
elle a chanté une pratique dos avec son
nez golasa c'était insupportable
bon alors tu ferais encore degen tchèque
ok bon je vous tue tous les deux bel
arrêt tabac droite lucas c'est de ta
faute tu peux y aller le get a room aux
canards dans les marais tu as dû lancer
n'importe quoi là encore non et loisy
quoi
je veux le silence et prochain qui taxe
le but c'est un budget mois +1 taille 1
je vois ton ombre du cap bon labyrinthe
c'était l'âge d'or de non vraiment vos
pièges mais ouais l'accusation 4 3 e 1
ont promis des cordes à sauter allez on
y va ce parti je suivais la droite la
main à droite la hague au sol après
reprocher un an j'en attends ok c'est
bon maintenant à l'offre continue hélas
le premier qu'il faut attendre minutes
d'accord
stop aux [ __ ] geste vous et sans dedola
la sotelma perte de la vie mais on peut
pas regarder une barrière saute la
barrière on peut pas aller à une
barrière mais marina fois et je me tiens
y'a des bye peu tout le monde dans
l'isolation c'est le décès imminent
on court on marche sur la tête chemise
et moi j'ai tiré un trait de jambes
j'avais tiré notre audience de quelques
uns sont sadc direct tout le monde dans
l'isolation vite que ça m'éclate et à
moins qu'un appel était perdu et les
huitièmes et tu te perds souvent
pourtant si tu as la même map
mais si je suis passé par là
attends tu fais un bisou c'est bien
aller tu vas dans l'isolation ok ok
qu'est ce qui se passe comme on la ferme
ta gueule d'accord mais bon nick est
l'apparition du ninja qu'animal est mal
connue et marseille c'est toi qui la
gueule chèques tout le monde contribue
en désolation à rio qui détour balle
envoyée
la surcharge être contre le mur de
l'infirmerie accroupi tout fait non seul
lé café lui une nouvelle salve tout seul
tu dis oh je regarde toi tu restes
contre le mur alors moi je veux partager
ma psy ou le sort de questions dégage
chercher mon lot c'est mon rallye dieu
oh [ __ ] jacques a déjà dit tout sur
jack attack ta gueule hugo vandamme et
regardent avant de mourir les items le
cas il est amoureux de toi mais c'est
pas ça la porte se ferme contre le mur
ok quand le murano ferme regardes tu as
vu comment glisser ce dernier cherche
midi dans sa cuisse gace tu lâches aux
normes ah ouais pulsions vexé jamais ri
tartas comme ça ok donc le premier je
voyais mort six mois maintenant comment
gérer sur mourir des offres de services
qui sont plus les autres bougies singes
outils sont pas là hugo vient étonnant
toi arrête de regarder là bas aux prises
des joueurs et du gol on n'y croyait pas
dans le stade mais il avait vu tu veux
prendre l'ascenseur et moi
je vais pas du tout ouais bah
et voilà les gens c'est déjà fort de
cette deuxième vidéo sur le mode badgers
j'espère que vous aura plu si c'est le
cas nous des faits mais la vidéo ça me
fera vraiment plaisir on se retrouve
très bientôt aux deux nouvelles vidéos
tient tout le monde
[Musique]
et
tél
[Musique]